it's time for a little tough love
stop focusing on what you don't have and
instead do what you can with what you do
have you have a lot of things that many
people do not you have food you have
internet you have clothes on your back
many many people have done a lot more
with a lot less than what you have right
now money will not solve your problem
because your mindset is broken you can
always find an excuse for not being
successful it can always be someone
else's fault blame your friends your
parents your country your financial
situation your lack of education and so
on this is important for you to know
understand that the conditions will
never be perfect
there was always something or someone to
blame the difference will happen for you
when you change your mindset you must
understand that you already have
everything you need to be successful
when you adopt that mindset then your
life will start to change dramatically
for the better I don't know if you're
ready to hear this message yet or if
you're gonna fight it and stick to your
old habits and beliefs I believe in you
it's time for you to believe in yourself
hi everyone my name is Colette I read I
recommend that you try out Evan
Carmichael's newsletters they've helped
me to restart my business and realize my
passion which is awesome
you